little fill in the blank time now chris
sims on this monday edition of pft live
the broncos and the rams are sending a
smaller group of people this year to the
scouting combine according to espn if
you gave teams truth serum they would
say the combine is
blank
spring break for nfl coaches that's what
they would tell you that's what it is i
mean hey the guy who's in row 95
who'd spent the night drinking
with other coaching buddies is not doing
anything worth the damn evaluating
players who are you know uh 150 yards
away right i mean
i understand then we're asking this
question in like right in lieu of the
broncos and rams and the fact that
they're you know not sending a whole lot
of people from their staffs i get it i
think that's what i would do you know
that's how rumors get started it's how
relationships back channels things like
that you know it's too much free time
and conversation if i was a head coach
of a team i'm not so sure i'd be very
happy about you know my coaches just
being off talking to other coaches and
doing all that you know you know working
out some some relationships or maybe
their future to where they may go
really the only guy mike you know this
too the only guys that need to be there
is the head coach the gm you know maybe
an assistant here and there to see
certain positions and that's it the the
fact of bringing i think the whole
organization
i think those days are numbered
yeah i agree with you and uh because
they're moving the workouts to prime
time
some of the prime drinking hours are
going to be wiped out thursday friday
saturday night they're gonna have to
start later than usual the restaurants i
had somebody tell me over the weekend
the people that run the restaurants are
not gonna be happy about this at all
right their biggest nights of the week
are gonna be wiped out or at least
they're gonna have to shift their hours
from you know five to midnight to like
11 to 5 a.m because everybody's going to
be tied up at lucas oil stadium for the
workout i want to see this become a
spectacle i mean i just let's do it like
and make the coach the gm and the owner
all sit there in the first three rows
you have them there fill out the rest of
the stadium with fans or whatever else
but make it look good for tv and let's
continue to go this route instead of a
scattered stadium of like there's johnny
assistant there's johnny assistant
there's that i'm telling you yeah that's
where it's heading and and indianapolis
indianapolis your days are numbered
hosting the scouting combine it's going
to be in l.a no matter how inconvenient
it is for everyone in la and at some
point the stadium's gonna be full and
let me tell you what too and i've seen
look this is a drum i've been banging
for several years now at some point
the players need to say
i'm not coming to that thing unless you
pay me yeah i hear you i'm not gonna be
a free participant in this reality show
that you guys are making more millions
off of you want me to show up you want
me to work out you pay me especially the
guys with the biggest names the guys
whose draft position yes joe
doing nothing for joe burrow nothing i
mean there's there's nothing i mean he's
going in the top five if he does if he
doesn't do one workout he's gonna go in
the top five
here's what i am waiting for a player to
say
when their season ends and they enter
the draft
everything you need to know about me is
on my game film from college anything
more you want from me i no i'm not this
isn't a job interview if you want me
draft me if you don't one of your
competitors will i'm not doing anything
and i'm not showing up for anything
unless you pay me because you're making
money off of it and i'm done doing stuff
for free i want to be paid for the
scouting combine i'm not doing a pro day
workout unless somebody wants to
compensate me for it and i'm not showing
up at the draft i'm not going to ride on
a boat in the fountain of the bellagio
and be a prop in your reality show if
you're not paying me and it's not enough
to bring me and my mom and my dad and my
brother and my sister and stay in a
hotel who cares you're getting paid
you're making money i'm getting paid or
i'm not showing up and i can't wait for
somebody to say that and basically say
hey
i'll see you at the draft if you pay me
otherwise draft me or don't but i'll
show up for the next thing when i get
paid for the first thing that i've ever
gotten paid for playing football well i
mean i hear you i hear you it's just
it's a tough thing to do for a young kid
who's about to reach his dream and
you're just not thinking that way either
and also you're thinking about trying
that's because they're all brainwashed i
think it's a dream well you're trying to
sell yourself too to position yourself
to become a higher draft pick to make
more money too though so
you know there's a little bit of that
balance as well but i hear you your
point's real man i mean i'm with you
like joe burrow chase young they could
probably pull that off this year and
nobody no you're not gonna stop them
they're going in the top five as long as
they like haven't murdered somebody and
aren't carrying around a glock on a
daily basis a gun or something like that
then they're going to the top five you
like that that took a very dark turn i
know
here's but here's the thing here's the
thing they they manipulate these guys
based upon their youth ego yeah
testosterone right it's very easy to
press the buttons of these guys in their
early 20s to get them to do whatever you
want right and i you know
it's easier the older you get to look at
and say these guys are getting screwed
but hey you know what joe burrow chase
young all you guys at the top you're
getting screwed you're getting screwed
all right this is fill in the blank we
need to move on you didn't even fill in
that blank only i did
yeah i you know and there's a lot i can
say about it but i think i've said
enough okay and
it is a reality show about nothing yes
the workouts are meaningless
this is about this is about the medical
that's all the combine is about it's the
medical everything else is just fluff
all right washington cut josh norman on
friday they still have to decide whether
to pick up the option on adrian
peterson's contract washington should
blank the 34 year old running back i say
pick up the option you know first off
this is not a running back group that's
going to make you feel warm and cozy if
you're a washington fan i mean what what
is there to really look at and be
dependable yeah darius geiss
is is uh talented but injury-prone as
we've seen through two years you know
chris thompson on the roster a lot of
talent but has an injury issues as well
there's nobody really there to trust uh
as far as a guy that you want to give
the ball to in big moments or protect
the ball running out the clock
and he still got some tread on those
tires so i would i would resign adrian
peterson i would pick up the option and
i would definitely keep him he is a
great leader he's a great presence in
the locker room he's a competitor and
and he's a draw how many how many guys
on that roster do you look at and say
wow there's a draw he's one of the few
that you look at and say hey that's a
guy that people show up to see yeah
you're right there's no doubt about he's
a legend i mean for me adrian peterson's
one of the three greatest running backs
of all time you know and what he's doing
at this age and the way he's moving is
is very special who are the other two uh
i i would go jim brown and barry sanders
and then adrian peterson i think those
would be my top three all time
certainly in my lifetime i think barry
sanders won adrian peterson two would be
the top two running backs i've ever seen
in person like at a game or just
watching on tv and having knowledge of
what's going on in football those two
are the two that jump out to me in their
prime
just added to the guest list for
indianapolis next week running back
frank gore will be on set again i love
you for another man to pick with chris
sims all right speaking of washington
greg olsen is negotiating with them
along with the seahawks and the bills
all things considered blank would be the
best of those options for greg olson
well i i you know i know ron rivera is
in washington but if i'm greg olsen i
don't want to go there you know i don't
want to go with a young quarterback and
deal with that so to me it's between the
seahawks and the bills one of those two
teams
oh i mean man it's really tough right
there but i'd probably go the seahawks
you know the bills have a young talented
tight end and that duke dawson kid or
dawson knox excuse me who they drafted
out of ole miss last year who's a damn
good player i think he's got like
superstar potential you know he goes
seattle they have they have a need at
that position and you know they will
continue to use and feature the tight
end position and russell wilson he knows
how to hit that type of guy so uh i
guess if i had to choose there between
the bills and the seahawks i go seahawks
well and for me best of the options is
none of the above i say walk through the
door at fox and take that seat in the
broadcast booth get off the football
field get yourself away from future
injury he's 35 years old and you know
he's doing the xfl games now for fox i
don't think they leave that door open
permanently no for him although they
seem to be willing to delay this
this transition one year at a time at a
time at a time at a time but i i think
that it may be and and he'll know when
the best offers are put on the table by
the three teams and then fox has their
offer and you know there may be a little
leverage play going on here hey fox are
you gonna sweeten it a little bit maybe
i won't play football if you offer me an
extra you know x dollars on top of what
you're currently offering or if you give
me this term or that term but there's
going to be a gap obviously it's going
to pay more to play football than it
will to work for fox but uh if he can
squeeze a better deal out of fox then so
be it maybe that's what he's trying to
do yeah it could be it really could i
mean i think he's got a future in
broadcasting no matter what and if you
just feel like you got that itch to play
you just got to play it out because
you'll be frustrated if you go down
jason whittonville and you're announcing
games and then you get towards the end
of that season go damn you know i should
have kept playing maybe what do i do
there so make sure it's all out make
sure it's all out your love of the game
everything is there and i would tell
greg go play it's all right that fox job
will be there he's handsome he's well
spoken he understands the game they'll
give him a job when that time comes
all right 49ers fullback kyle used chick
defended teammate jimmy garoppolo during
a recent appearance on nfl network the
fact that multiple 49ers have defended
garoppolo since the super bowl makes you
feel blank about the san francisco
quarterback chris but you know
more confident about the san francisco
quarterback
you know i think that the
the defense the staunch defense of the
49ers players i think there's some merit
here to what they're doing i think if
jimmy garoppolo
was really not a good player and a guy
that the team didn't see a lot of talent
with a future with i don't think you
would get the
the the defense that he's been getting
the last few weeks here
uh if that was the case i think the team
goes hey we like the guy they like the
leader i think they like the player and
the talent they see and i think they
think this is unjust and i think that's
something to be said because i think if
the players really thought he was crappy
and not the guy you wouldn't get this
kind of defense of him
i think it makes me feel no differently
about the san francisco quarterback
they're doing what they have to do it's
what peter king said super bowl week
yeah or i think it was super bowl week
the idea that right that you know any
time look
at any time
there are external voices
that are picking on a player on a team
whatever sport it may be
the team's going to rally around the guy
unless he's just a complete jerk
they're going to rally around him
and they'll deal with their concerns
privately but if you criticize our
quarterback you're criticizing all of us
and they know it's not in their best
interest to stay silent in the face of
that and use checks remarks
ultimately underscore the main concern
here jimmy garoppolo had a chance to win
a super bowl with a throw to an open
emanuel and he failed to make it right
that's the criticism when the season's
riding on it and you know mike reese of
espn.com had a great quote from tom
brady about jimmy garoppolo and
basically saying hey i'm looking forward
to seeing him play in the super bowl
that's when you find out what you're
made of well we found out yeah what
jimmy garoppolo's made of he didn't make
the throw that tom brady would have made
that other quarterbacks have made that's
the that's the gist of the criticism at
this point he had a chance to win a
super bowl and didn't that's it it's not
inaccurate no no i i you're right i
understand that but i do think there is
something there to be like to me the the
cr the defense of the 49ers has been
much more aggressive from the player's
standpoint
than it was even for let's just say kirk
cousins until the very end of this
season right to me i just i feel like
you know it just shows something that
he's really well liked within the locker
room that's i guess what i'm saying more
than anything that they have confidence
in them that he's well-liked but you're
right the thoughts on the field they're
still those questions are real and your
questions are real too you know i'm
going to be one that's going to sit here
and go hey listen you know i knew he
wasn't patrick mahomes and that game was
there to be had by that defense that
defense should have won that's the way
the team was built and they were up 20
to 10 and it was third and 15. and they
got mahomes they got mahomes that might
have to become a phrase it really might
i watched that damn thing mike the nfl
miced up like 40 minute show with my
little boy of the the super bowl again
it's just amazing that game it's worth
the watch too mike but it's just again i
just
walked away just going that's
unbelievable damnedest thing i ever saw
team was gonna lose and then 15 just
caught fire and they scored 21 points in
six minutes against the best pass
defense we've seen in football in the
last 12 years it just to me is still
insane and i just err on that greatness
more than blaming jimmy garoppolo so
much i guess is where i come from
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports